Balaji a huge victory for you
back-to-back victories right now you're
fully back in this tournament but this
wasn't straightforward and especially
this move Bishop to D7 early on in the
game it definitely felt like it
surprised you it surprised everybody
tell us about this yeah I mean I feel
like this was such like I mean this this
line has been played for hundreds of
years and suddenly did like make bishop
D7 which I've never seen before so I was
definitely surprised I felt it should be
a bit dubious but I thought maybe later
it wasn't so without reason because
trading office Bishops really helped him
later on as
um usually his light squared Bishop
would be worse but in this case I
definitely think I maybe forged things
too much maybe I should split slower
because as soon as this now you're gone
to B4 I felt that this was super
annoying I couldn't figure out how to
get rid of it and here by already I feel
like he basically he equalized without
too much trouble you thought that he
could last year yeah and it was not and
I think you you objectively you were
definitely right but yeah you still had
some tension maybe that favors you right
in the position yeah I mean I didn't
want it for fall on D6 yeah I didn't see
anything too easy to play with so I was
just trying to like slowly make moves
trying to see because I knew he has to
go to D5 seemed like the critical line
all the time so I was waiting for him
just trying to get ready for D5 as much
as possible and trying to get this type
of structure and trying to figure out
okay how do I want to play after he
plays this and the way I dealt with it
maybe it's not the best
but it at least kept some play on the
board I liked it I really like this
transfer of the rookon G3 and this was
the critical moment when he played this
King to h8 battle would have been Knight
to E4 but the position already gets a
little bit dangerous yeah with so many
pieces swarming around the king king h8
and you came up with this idea yeah I
don't I don't think Bishop takes H6 I
don't think it was the cleanest what was
the critical line that you I mean I
thought she takes H6 has to be Knight D6
Queen C7 and what I forgot about is
Queen F4 Queen C1
take take and I forgot his check still I
thought I can take the Rook on E8 and
that it's just full Rook but no let's
check and so he gets away and this is
just winning for him yeah and in fact I
think the best move was King H3 yeah I
thought about King rookie when I wasn't
sure what I was gonna play it because I
did see this I didn't see that after
oftics E5 I saw he can cleanly grab this
pawn and all the stuff after Knight
takes Queen takes and queen D4 he has F6
which is very important oh 96 actually
okay yeah
perhaps you can take on A5 first yeah
yeah queen queen B2 through this that's
probably more accurate yeah still a
complete mess yeah I mean this is very
playable so I wouldn't say like one side
is better I think it's unclear anything
can happen here but
I would probably choose white in time
trouble at least just because we can
yeah yeah no it definitely felt like
completely crazy position he spent a lot
of time took on E5 and after that
this moment came yeah I mean what when
he saw this move Knight C6 what what was
your rear because he still had time it's
not like he was in a huge hurry to make
his move I mean honestly I wasn't okay
of course I was a bit surprised you saw
it immediately you saw the show I saw
this beforehand because I thought Knight
C6 he might play this because if there's
no Rook H4 it's a very logical move
you're just you're not you don't want to
put your Rook on it which looks very
yeah
um but it's sometimes it's just like a
blind spot forgetting you can go all the
way in especially after such a sudden
change in position whereas like it's
literally like terrible for him to
suddenly like it's really hard to defend
such a structure I think a sudden change
in probably all that just in his head
kind of just made him forget well he
lost patience and you definitely took
advantage of that congratulations for uh
this important Victory thank you guys
back to you yeah our congratulations and
welcome back to the tournament yeah
congratulations to a very important win
I mean you won with one of the leaders
my question is what are your plans for
the rest day now that you kind of caught
up with the maybe the you know the major
players in the field I mean I wouldn't
say I have anything too special planned
it's more just resting and getting ready
for these final four rounds which will
be very crucial I think because this
tournament is definitely opening up so
anything can happen anymore
okay great so we should good rest in the
in the during the rest day and for the
rest of the tournament thank you